anti-semitism is a real thing of vile
pernicious potentially fatal poison
which caused the annihilation of
millions of Jewish people in Europe in
the 1930s and 1940s and but for the Red
Army and the other Allies it might well
have been that every single last Jewish
person in Europe perhaps beyond Europe
would have been literally wiped off the
face of the earth so it's a very serious
business dealing with anti-semitism the
weaponization of anti-semitism against
people not in the least guilty of it is
equally a serious matter the danger is
if you're calling everyone anti-semitic
the whole Labor Party the whole labor
movement the whole carbon movement then
the real anti-semites can go about their
evil potentially fatal business
unnoticed so the boy who cried wolf is a
useful parable and we are so far down
the rabbit hole now of the weaponization
of anti-semitism as a political issue
that it has become not just unjust not
just immoral but positively dangerous
and dangerous to Jewish people
themselves the idea that Jeremy Corbyn
whom I have known since the 1970s is an
anti-semite is as absurd as it is
offensive Chris Williamson - the Labour
MP once again suspended for
anti-semitism when not a scintilla of
anti-semitism or any other form of
racism is present in his mind in his
soul these are dangerous reckless
irresponsible allegations these people
with their record collections full of
Bob Dylan their bookshelves filled with
Noam Chomsky and Karl Marx and professor
Norman Finkelstein mind you were so far
down the rabbit hole
both professor Finkelstein and norm
Chomsky have also themselves been
accused of anti-semitism this is a trick
that we play said Shulamit Aloni a
former Israeli minister to me over
dinner in her house in Tel Aviv more
than 30 years ago she repeated it on
television you can google it and find it
this is a trick we play
she said the smearing of supporters of
Palestinian rights the smearing of
opponents of Israeli policies and
practices as anti-semitism is a weapon
of war it's a mechanised industrialized
weapon of war and it's time to say this
far and no further
not least because coming along soon is
the presidential run of senator Bernie
Sanders like Chomsky and Finkelstein
himself Jewish but under accusation of
anti-semitism I shouldn't need to be
saying this but the idea that senator
Bernie Sanders is an anti-semite is
itself foul and poisonous I have no
doubt that if Bernie Sanders is the
Democratic nominee for president in 2020
that the carbon treatment will be
afforded to him with knobs on it because
of course being the president of the
United States is the most powerful
elected office on the planet so I'm
saying we need to make a very careful
studied dichotomy between anti-semitism
and criticism of Israel support for the
Palestinian people carbon Williamson not
guilty of the first guilty of the second
Sanders not guilty of the first
absolutely guilty of the second we
oppose Netanyahu
we love Jews
that's the message